- Lets talk Handmaids Tale, though.
Your brother, I heard, dressed up
as your character, is this true?
- Yeah.
When a family member comes to set,
you put them in the Handmaid's costume.
It's like one of the
great gifts of the show
is the ability to do that.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] You're gonna look so pretty!
Oh my god he looks like a serial killer!
(audience laughs)
- [Elizabeth] Yes, he does
look like a serial killer.
- [Kelly] Look at how creepy that is!
- With his like Adidas
shoes and his beard.
- Oh my God!
- Look at how he's taking it so seriously,
I think he looks lovely.
- [Kelly] I think he looks like
the best serial killer I've ever seen.
Speaking of this role, though
you play some pretty intense roles.
I mean, are you like attracted to those?
Like, what do you do to unwind
from all of that seriousness.
- You know, I love Hallmark movies.
- Oh, you go opposite?
- I do.
(audience applause)
I mean they're really good.
- [Kelly] My sister is obsessed.
- Love them especially the
Hallmark Christmas movies.
- My sister's obsessed.
- Yes, I mean this is like we love these.
They're really great.
They're happy and they always end happy
and we discover the magic of Christmas
and it's wonderful.
- Like oh my gosh, they got together.
I never thought it was gonna happen.
- It's amazing.
- [Kelly] They're together, it's amazing.
- I have the Hallmark app on my phone.
- [Kelly] A Hallmark app? (laughing)
- That's how you watch the movies, Kelly.
- I didn't actually know that existed.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
My sister probably has it.
- Oh yeah, and I actually
talked recently about
my love for Hallmark
Christmas movies especially
and like the next day Hallmark
reached out and was like
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah and was like we
would love to do something
with you, and I wanted
to make it really clear
that I wasn't kidding.
Like I wasn't making fun of them,
this wasn't ironic,
I was like I want to do a
Hallmark Christmas movie.
There's a seminal, right?
(applause)
- There's no making fun of it.
It's a huge thing.
- It's a huge thing and
- Like most females I know are like what
especially at Christmas.
- We all watch them and I wanna make like
a real Hallmark Christmas movie.
I wanna do all of the things
so we're actually looking into it
and we might do something.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- I know.
(applause)
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- Thank you.